let's imagine a very simple world as we
tend to do in economics that has two
countries that are each capable of
producing either pants or shirts or some
combination and so what we have here are
the production possibility curve for
each of those countries and this is in
per worker per day so for example in
country a part worker per day they could
if they put all of their energy into
pants they could produce 20 if they put
all their energy into shirts they could
produce 10 or there could be some
combination that would sit on this line
now to help us digest the production
possibility curve for these two
countries let me construct an output
table so this will be this column will
be the output for country a this column
will be the output for country B and
we're gonna think about the maximum
number of pants maximum pants the
maximum output of pants per worker per
day the input is the worker per day and
then let's think about the maximum
number of shirts so pause this video and
see if you can fill this out what are
the max pants and shirts in country a
and Country B well in country I already
talked about it the maximum pants is
2020 pants and then the maximum shirts
if they didn't make any pants are 10 and
in country B the maximum pants are 30
and the maximum shirts it looks like
that is about 45 now from either these
production possibility curve or from
this output table because we have a
constant opportunity cost these
production possibility curve are
straight lines with a fixed slope we can
calculate the opportunity cost so let's
do that next so this is country a and
then this is country B and let me
calculate the opportunity cost of pants
and let's calculate the opportunity cost
of shirts so pause this video and see if
you can figure that out what are the
opportunities of pants and shirts in
countries a and B and fill out this
table well one way to think about it in
country a I could put all of my energy
into pants and produce 20 pants or I
could put all of my energy into shirts
and produce 10 shirts 10 shirts s for
sure it's P for pants
and so if I want the cost of pants I
could just divide both sides by 20 and I
would get pants the amount of energy per
pant is equal to well 10 divided by 20
is 1/2 a shirt so the energy for pant is
1/2 4 it is the same as the energy for
half a shirt and so we could say the
opportunity cost of producing a pant is
half a shirt if we want the opportunity
cost for shirts we could take the
reciprocal of this number we could say
it's going to be 2 over 1 pants or we
could start with this equation right
over here and instead of solving for P
we could solve for s how much energy in
terms of pants does it take for us to
produce one shirt so if you divide both
sides of this equation by 10 you would
get you would get 2 P is equal to s or
another way of thinking about it the
energy to create one shirt is equal to
the energy to create 2 pants so the
opportunity cost of producing a shirt is
2 pants so that same energy of the shirt
you could produce 2 pants now let's also
fill it out for country B and if you
haven't done so already try to use the
same method to fill this the opportunity
cost for pants and shirts for country B
well in country B I could put all of my
energy into pants and produce 30 pants
or all of my energy and two shirts and
produce 45 shirts so the opportunity
cost per pant if I divide both sides by
30 it would be 45 over 30 which would be
equal to they're both divisible by 15
three halves of a shirt the energy for
one pair of pants is the same as the
energy for one and a half shirts I guess
I could say so let me write it that way
so the opportunity cost of pants is for
each pair I'm giving up one and a half
shirts and then in the opportunity cost
for shirts well I could just solve for s
here if I divide both sides by 45 I get
the same energy for one shirt would be
thirty forty fifth of a pair of pants
which is the same thing as 2/3 of a pair
of pants and so I could write that as
2/3 of a pair of pants or if I
let me just write it that way two-thirds
of a pair of pants so given the
opportunity costs what should each of
these countries focus on pause this
video and try to figure that out well
let's first compare their opportunity
costs in pants
so let's first compare their opportunity
cost in pants it is clear that country a
has a lower opportunity cost for
producing a pair of pants it's only
giving up half a shirt while country B
is giving up one and a half shirts so
country a has the comparative advantage
right over here so comparative advantage
right over here in pants and so it
should focus all of its energy according
to the theory of comparative advantage
it should focus all of its energy on
pants and likewise if we look at so here
we compared this to this and likewise if
we try to look at shirts right over here
if we look at their opportunity costs
country B is only giving up two-thirds
of a pair of pants while country a would
be giving up two pairs of pants so
country B has the lower opportunity cost
or the comparative advantage in shirts
so country B should put all of their
focus here on shirts now I know what you
might be thinking people can't just walk
around wearing only shirts that might
people might get cold below their waist
or people don't want to wear only wear
pants they might get cold above their
waist and so how can people in these
countries get the other type of garment
well the obvious answer is if they focus
in this way they can trade and what
would be an acceptable trading price
let's say for pants let's focus on pants
for a second so if we're thinking about
the market for pants so if your country
a what would you be willing to sell
pants for in terms of shirts well a good
price so to speak would be something
higher than your opportunity cost
so a willing to sell
sell pants at price I'll put that in
quotes because we're really thinking of
price in terms of another good at price
greater than their opportunity cost
greater than 1/2 of a shirt and you
could think of this willing to trade or
sell I'll put that in quotes they're
really trading in our everyday language
right over here and likewise what about
country be well be willing to buy pants
they need pants there otherwise they
would just be walking around with only
shirts on willing to buy pants at a
price at a price less than their
opportunity costs for pants and so that
would be less than 1.5 of a shirt so
what would be a price that is greater
than half a shirt and less than 1/2 and
less than 1 and 1/2 of a shirt and
really any price in between these two
values would work well a nice round
number is well they could trade at one
pair of pants for one shirt so a
clearing price a price that would work
could be 1p one pants for one shirt and
now let's appreciate the gains from
trade that they would both have here so
let's imagine this world where country a
is producing 20 pants per worker per day
but let's say they decide that they want
instead of those 20 pants they would
want to trade 15 of them away for shirts
and so they would get at this price they
would get 15 shirts so they're gonna
give up 15 pants they're giving up 15
pants so they'll only have 5 pants right
over here
but they're going to get 15 shirts so
they're gonna get 15 shirts and they're
going to end up right over here this is
where a country a is going to end up and
what's cool about this is we've gone
beyond the production possibilities
curve so you see Claire
clearly the gain from trade country--a
could not have gotten to this point on
its own this is above the production
possibilities curve
likewise country B was over here with 45
shirts it gave up 15 of those shirts it
now has 30 shirts but it now has 15
pants at least some of the people in the
country are going to be able to wear
pants now so it now has 15 pants once
again it too is in a point beyond its
production possibilities curve it would
not have been able to get here without
the trade so they are both better off
so the key thing the key takeaway from
this video is we now appreciate why
comparative advantage is valuable once
again making all the assumptions for
these simplified economic models because
we can calculate our opportunity cost
from that comparative advantage and then
we could think about what's a good price
that they'll be willing to trade at and
see that when they trade they both are
able to get beyond their production
possibilities curve